I'm a bit of an amateur chuffing courage
hohoho
but when what Aventis is thoroughly
mixed up as this one is many people
think that there'll be a red black red
black red black I'm not talking about
suits now just the colour this a red
bike but it doesn't happen that way for
example here we got three Reds and we
don't do the choker in there yes and
we've got oh there's another three Reds
no this is pretty good the the colours
I'm just looking at the colours now
the colours are pretty well mixed in
here there's another joker that we all
right now what I'm going to do is first
of all we suspect that the coat of a the
colours would be pretty well sorted
they've been alternated all the way
through the deck but I'm going to show
you something rather remarkable here we
have a well shuffle deck very well
shuffle deck and I want you to come over
here and just give me your hand if you
would be so kind step over to join me on
this head okay now just hold on like
that with the palm up little closer I
see you have a rich future yes well in
any case I want you to hold half of the
cards for me would you please and I'll
hold the other half and I'm going to
show you something rather remarkable
look at this I would have turned the
backpack over watch this one black card
on the top and then all the rest of them
read every last one
Wow and taking a look hold those for me
please number one black card on the top
just to disguise it but in this case
each and every one of them black
you